james bond is one of the all-time great
movie characters he's suave he's tough
and he's got a fashion sense to die for
but what's the real story behind the
scenes of britain's most iconic film
franchise
this is the untold truth of james bond
before there were the james bond movies
they were the james bond novels
written by ian fleming the 14 bond books
were kind of a fantasy version of
lemming's real life experiences as a
member of british naval intelligence
the author was a total unknown when
casino royale was set to be published
but he was determined to make his book a
hit
and routinely sent out signed copies of
his book to as many newspaper and
magazine editors as he could
despite his efforts however the book
still wasn't selling well especially in
america
but everything changed when fleming came
across the perfect opportunity to get
his name out there
after the suez crisis the british prime
minister anthony eden's health had begun
to deteriorate and he found himself in
need of a place to relax
always wanted to take an opportunity
fleming eagerly offered the politician
access to goldeneye his secluded home in
jamaica
the author was thrilled by the visit
hoping eden stay at goldeneye would
boost the sales of his book
and believe it or not the crazy
publicity stunt actually worked
thrusting fleming into the public eye
and making his stories famous around the
world
growing up in new york albert cubby
brockley worked on his uncle's farm
which primarily grew the family's
signature vegetable broccoli
but young cubby didn't want to spend his
entire life working in the dirt so he
took his chances and moved to hollywood
in the 1930s
after slowly working his way up in the
industry brockley ended up co-producing
the first feature film adaptation of ian
fleming's james bond spy novels
during his search for the titular hero
broccoli heard an actor named sean
connery might be a good choice for the
role so he went to see the scotsman and
darby o'gill and the little people
brockley was impressed with connery's
work on the movie but wondered if the
actor had the raw sex appeal needed for
bond so he showed his wife the film too
she of course made it clear that connery
was more than capable in this department
though the movie's studio united artists
threw around a number of names for the
role broccoli fought for connery and won
and so began one of the longest running
film series in history
i admire your luck mr
bond james bond
though sean connery is typically known
as the first proper bond two other
actors actually played the role before
him
in 1954 cbs paid fleming a thousand
dollars for the rights to casino royale
and turned the novel into a one-hour tv
special for the series climax
for the first glimpse of bond in the
flash they cast barry nelson
an actor who had starred in a ton of tv
shows in his time but you'll probably
recognize him best as stuart ullman the
guy who hires jack nicholson to take
care of the overlook hotel and the
shining
after the tv version a south african
radio station produced an adaptation of
moonraker featuring the vocal talents of
bob pulnes
if you're an american that name might
not mean much but if you're from the uk
you'd know him as the host of various
game shows particularly of the
long-running trivial pursuit like
blockbusters
luckily the idea of game show host
playing james bond doesn't seem to
become a tradition
so there's been an irish bond there's
been a scottish bond there was even an
australian bond albeit briefly
but to this day an american has never
donned the tuxedo for a feature film
although one came incredibly close after
filming for your eyes only roger moore
was ready to turn in his license to kill
and james brolin was one of the top
choices to replace the british star for
octopussy
despite his american accent brolin
perfected his britishism so well that he
was even tentatively offered the role
for a short amount of time
unfortunately for brolin roger moore
decided to come back to the franchise
after all
killing any dreams of an american bond
maybe one day
having opened in 1935 pinewood studios
has been with bond since the very
beginning
but during their 60 years of filming
there the franchise's cast and crew have
endured their fair share of disasters
in 1984 the stage on which most of the
bond films were shot
tragically burned to the ground it took
a full year to rebuild and it was
eventually renamed as the albert r
broccoli 007 stage in honor of the
legendary producer
unfortunately the double 07 stage burned
down again in 2006
at the time the double 07 stage was
actually being used for a bond movie and
the blaze ended up destroying the fake
venice used in casino royale
luckily the filmmakers had just finished
shooting no one was hurt and there
weren't any dangerous pyrotechnics or
flammable objects around to make things
worse
even so it took around 90 minutes to get
the fire under control
by 2007 the double 07 stage was open
again
newly enlarged and now it's one of the
biggest sound stages in europe
james bond has always pulled out the
stops when it comes to theme songs
among the legendary artists who have
written for the franchise are shirley
bassey paul mccartney madonna gladys
knight carly simon
tom jones and ace of base yes indeed the
90s swedish pop group ace of base was
actually hired to ride a bond theme
where pierce brosnan's bond debut
goldeneye sadly the head honchos at our
wrist at records the label that
represented the band thought goldeneye
was going to be a flop
and they didn't want their primo band
associated with failure so artista
pulled ace of base from the project and
the james bond folks went with
tina turner instead however the swedish
band did rename their track the juvenile
and if you're interested you can still
hear the double-oh-seven song that could
have been
a number of other famous artists have
written bond themes over the years too
only to follow the final hurdle blondie
were locked in to pen the title track to
for your eyes only for a while
johnny cash wrote his own version of
thunderball and pulp almost did the
theme for tomorrow never dies
even radiohead almost got in on the bond
action writing a title track for spectre
that sadly was rejected by producers
because it was in their opinion too dark
for the movie
after sean connery left the franchise
the producers were adamant that they
should find the perfect replacement for
him but nobody could have guessed it
would be george lazenby
the australian car mechanic who fell
into male modeling according to lazenby
he had never acted in his life but when
he got the info about auditions during
the threesome the man decided he would
work as hard as he could to win the
producers over
over the next four months they made him
jump through a number of poops including
a screen test with a wrestler who lays
and be accidentally knocked out
then in a genuinely shocking move the
producer sent him a sex worker to make
sure he wasn't gay
this never happened to the other fella
given that he allegedly ended up
sleeping with almost every girl on set
however it seems like lazenby passed
that particularly disturbing test
in fact lazenby actually did well with
his first bond film on her majesty's
secret service and was even offered a
one million dollar contract to star in
six more movies
but his agent at the time told him to
turn it down according to his agent the
bond age was over and people were more
into gritty films like easy rider
so lazenby left bond behind and was
eternally blackballed for being a nobody
that turned down the biggest franchise
around
roger moore was a man of many talents
not only did he play double07 but he has
also written about the iconic spy too
in his book bond on bond more gives
ample insight into the world of ian
fleming's character
and while moore provides all sorts of
interesting behind-the-scenes details he
drops
one informational nugget that's
particularly surprising
though the franchise has flourished for
years moore says that during his time
playing bond he got by largely without
the help of a script
back in moore's day before shooting
began the basic plot was laid out and
the action set
pieces were in place but all that snappy
dialogue was constantly changing from
the first read to the final shooting
dates
often while on set with director lewis
gilbert moore would have his lines
memorized and ready to go when gilbert
would suddenly decide they could do
better and basically flush the script
down the toilet
and while moore admits that this was
probably frustrating for the
screenwriters he also suggests that the
paychecks were big enough to make up for
it
timothy dalton was one of the top
choices to replace sean connery in 1969
but dalton himself felt he was too young
for the role
luckily the producers didn't forget his
name and by the time roger moore decided
to leave the series they had swung back
around to dalton
since it had been almost 20 years from
the first request dalton finally felt he
was old enough to take on the role
the walsh actor played a much less
comedic version of double-oh-seven in
the living daylights and licensed to
kill and he was all set to do a third
but a legal dispute put the film on hold
and released dalton from his contractual
obligations
when the studio was ready to start up
the franchise again dalton had decided
he only wanted to return one last time
but after such a long wait between
movies the producers wanted a bond who
would stick around for a while
so dalton passed the torch to the next
fella while pierce brosnan first donned
the james bond suit for goldeneye he was
actually meant to show up a little bit
earlier
the irish actor was first offered the
role for the living daylights but he
couldn't get out of his tv contract for
remington steel
fortunately the producers came back
around to brosnan when he was
conflict-free
but while he brought in new energy to
the franchise brosnan never felt happy
with his performances bond
as the man himself put it i felt i was
caught in a time warp between roger
moore and sean connery the violence was
never real the brute force of the man
was never palpable
it was quite tame and the
characterization didn't have a follow
through of reality it was surface
but then that might have had to do with
my own insecurities and playing him as
well
as the latest actor to play james bond
daniel craig has plenty of mixed
feelings about the iconic role
he takes the film seriously and loves
the work of course but also once called
the role a drag and has occasionally
insisted he wants nothing less than to
never play the role again
more recently however he has walked back
those comments calling his gig as the
super spy the best job in the world
so what's up with the mixed emotions
well maybe craig feels so conflicted
because bond is his complete opposite as
the actor once told time
out i was aware of what was needed to be
bond but it still goes against
everything i believe in
you've met me a couple of times i'm not
very cool but
bond has to be cool he goes on to say
and that often feels awkward for him
though you'd never guess that daniel
craig thinks he's kind of a dork it's
easy to understand the pressure of
playing the smoothest character in film
history
still if the popular reception to his
bond is anything to go by
craig really doesn't have anything to
worry about
the name's bond james bond
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one